hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today I'm gonna be
going over the Rosalie MO variation it's
kind of the anti Sicilian so it's a very
strong variation in the Sicilian offense
Sicilian pon e4 pawn c5 Knight f3 knight
c6 and then Bishop to b5 now if the
bishop comes here to b5 that's the
Rosalia variation the knight doesn't
have to be here but really I think the
Rose elimination shines if your
opponent's 9 here is on c6 so if it's
night here if it's not there if they see
pawn to d6 you can feel free to bring
your Bishop up here but I really
recommend it more if the nights here on
c6 so this is gonna be what we're gonna
be talking about today some of the main
lines that we're gonna be talking about
whites Maine's goal is to give up his
Bishop 4 doubled pawns here on the C
file so it doesn't really matter where
your opponent goes more than likely not
gonna be moving this Knight because that
doesn't make a ton of sense but wherever
your opponent moves you're gonna be
taking this Knights giving your opponent
doubled pawns here on the C file now
your opponent could decide to play
knight here to d4 I recognize that you
can play 90 or c3 different video we're
gonna be talking about but in this
particular video we're gonna talk about
what happens if your opponent leaves to
the 9 here on c6 which is the most
common the most common move the traction
I see after this after the bishop comes
here to b5 is pawn to g6 get him ready
to fianchetto as bishop here to g7
control this long dark diagonal that he
already has his pawn here on c5
attacking and then try to win the game
from there as we talked about before
White's gameplan is always going to be
take this knight and then see what your
opponent does the first thing that we're
gonna be looking at is if the pawn takes
here on c6 do recognize thinking else to
take with the other pawn so we're gonna
look at that as well but if this pawn
takes right here it's gonna be very
simple White's gonna play pawn to d3
solidifying this pawn chain right here
his light square bishop is already
outside of the pawn chain has already
been sacrificed for the greater good so
it's okay to go ahead and play your pawn
here because it's not blocking off
anything it also opens up the door for
this dark square Bishop to get involved
into the game especially if your
opponent castles on the King side which
more than likely we know is gonna happen
since there's an opus in the open B file
right here this dark diagonal is gonna
be very very key for white to go ahead
and get his
we're a bishop involved into the game
now from here a few ways that black can
continue but usually if again you see
this pawn here to do six he's looking to
fee and kiddo as a bishop here to do
seven after the bishop comes here we're
gonna play King castling on the Kings
side we actually could play Knight here
to c3 but it gets tricky just because
there's a nice little trap you actually
have in a few more moves and also your
opponent could just take here give you
double pawns as well I think it's just a
little bit easier to keep your opponent
with the doubled pawns and just continue
with the game plan so we're gonna play
instead of Knight to c3 we're gonna
castle on the King side and then see
what our opponent does one thing that
our opponent might do is play rook to b8
again you always want to get your rooks
involved into the game rook to b8 seems
pretty logical it's getting this rook
over to the semi open file controls a
lot of the board now black has a rook
and a bishop both aimed at this pawn on
b2 now typically if you look at this you
would say okay I need to go ahead and
play something that blocks these move
you could see pawn here 2 to c3 you
could try to stop it with Knight here to
c3 because again white only has one
defender on this pawn and black has two
attackers but instead White's gonna kind
of play dumb and set a trap and instead
he's gonna play tonight here to d2 1
this is a great square because it also
defends this night here on f3 White's a
little bit more focused right now on the
light squares we can easily centralize
his Knight if it wants to but again this
sets a trap because his opponent
technically can't take this pawn without
giving up material now if he takes with
his Bishop White has two ways to go
about doing this he can take with his
his Bishop and then after the rook comes
down he can swing him with his Knights
and actually block this rook so that's
one way another way is after the bishop
takes the rook can just swing over here
to b1 now if the bishop takes here on C
1 then the rook can swing up here even
if the bishop takes here on the 2y it's
definitely gonna be up in material we're
gonna swing the rook over here to B 1
this is gonna be very very difficult for
black to deal with so White has all this
heavy hitters it's gonna be
difficult for black to get his other
heavy-hitters involvement of the game
can't move his light square bishop for a
long time he's gonna be very very hard
pressed white can really start to attack
some of these other pieces over here
this pawn over here on a 7 could fall
potentially so definitely gonna be very
very bad for black now if we come back
here and say okay what if black takes
with his rook same kind of action we're
gonna go ahead and take with our bishop
right here and after the bishop takes
then the Brooks gonna swing over here to
be one and this is gonna be very very
good for white so while it looks like a
black can go ahead and come down and
take that material he actually can't in
practice so it's definitely gonna be
good again to bring your knight over
here to b2 and then continue with a game
now if black recognizes he can't take
this more than likely he now wants to
castle he needs to get some Kings side
safety it's gonna be a tough road from
him so he could play Knight to f6 seems
like the most logical move definitely
wants to get his keen castled on the
Kings side and so from here what do we
do we're gonna push forward with pawn to
e5 forcing this material to move right
here we do have a protector with our
nights here on f3 protecting this from
this bishop so after the knight moves
then we have another interesting move
that we can do and that is Knight to b3
again kind of stopping what we talked
about before but it also threatens this
pawn here on c5 and there's only a few
ways to really defend this the Queen can
come here to b6 and the pawn can come
here to d6 now it's actually important
for this pawn to come to these six
because this light-square bishop for
black can kind of hone down and own this
long diagonal if instead the Queen comes
to b6 trying to protect this material
right here then Y can just win with pawn
to g4 there's no way to stop this this
nights going to fall that's definitely
going to be very very good for white so
again it's important to play this pawn
to d6 to kind of open up that so that
white can no longer play pawn here to d4
but because of that y can play here
taking on d6 and after it takes right
here then the rook can swing over to e1
putting a lot of pressure on black right
here we could see Bishop coming here to
eat
night here to g5 again more and more
pressure from white this is definitely
gonna be a very very good game for might
now the next variation we're gonna go
over is if the pons takes here on a c6
we just lucked it what happens when the
pawn takes from b7 so after the pawn
takes here on d6 it opens it up a little
bit more for the Queen black also has
the potential to castle on the Queen
side although it would be pretty risky
but he does have a little bit more
openness in this particular game so from
here why it's gonna continue with the
same gameplay and he's gonna play pawn
here to d3 again solidify this pawn
chain his LightSquared bishop doesn't
have to worry about getting outside that
pawn chain so that's no worries from
there the bishops now gonna come to g7
again attacking this long diagonal but
White's gonna actually have an
interesting move here that's gonna be a
little bit different he's gonna play
pawn here to h3 it's not super
aggressive but it actually saves a lot
of heartache because you really don't
want in this particular game to have
your opponent bring his Bishop here to
d4 pinning down your knight it's very
very very annoying so just go ahead and
play this pawn to h3 it just allows you
more flexibility and kind of see what
your opponent's gonna do if your
opponent now plays Knight to f6
you could play Knight here to c3 again
you're not really trying to set up a
trap because again the rook is not here
on b8 so we can't come down here anyway
so Knight to c3 is fine it's not even
worried about the attack from the bishop
over here on g7 so we could see King
castling over here and then Bishop here
to e3 and this is important because now
the Queen can come here to d2 it can
kind of protect it if the bishop now
wants to come over here to h6 kind of
break up the King side and then white
still has the option you can castle on
the Queen side he can castle on the King
side so he's developing naturally his
opponent has doubled pawns and he still
has a lot of flexibility is how as far
as how he wants to continue the next
version that we're gonna look at is pawn
to e6 getting ready to play Knight here
to e7 to protect this Knight over here
why it's not really gonna waste a lot of
time he's gonna play Bishop takes here
and just see what his opponent does
again the first one we're gonna look at
is with the pawn takes here on c6
White's gonna continue with the same
game plan of pawn to d3
now usually when the pawn comes to
six blacks looking to push forward with
pawn here to d5 because he has so many
attackers now he can kind of
counter-attack the light squares it's
very important this position for white
not to take he does not want to give up
central control the board if he plays
pawn here to d5 his opponent can take
black no longer has doubled pawns and
black completely dominates the center of
the board with his pawns you'd never
have to rush to take your opponent's
moves and said you can just continue
with your own development from here y
can play castle on the kingside black
really wants to take but he really can't
because after the pawns takes the pawn
recaptures all of a sudden if we look at
it white still controls the center of
the board with the light squares he has
both his Knight and his pawn but black
has double pawns here on the C file but
he no longer has pawns on B or D files
so it's gonna be even harder for him to
protect both of these pawns again much
better setup than when your opponent has
three pawns in the center board and he
controls the entire center so we come
back here again we don't have to commit
and take we can just go ahead and castle
on the King side if your opponent now
decides to play something Knight to f6
if we wanted to now we can play Knight
to c3 again continuing with our own
development if we see pawn here to d4
that's going to be completely fine and
I'm here to a5 starting to put more
pressure on these double pawns that we
see here on the C file now if we come
back to the beginning if your opponent
doesn't take with a be pawn instead he
takes with his deep on again very very
common we're gonna play pawn here to d3
it'll kind of get a theme this is pretty
easy for white to play because he's
gonna be doing the same thing over and
over
Knight to f6 pretty common getting ready
to Bishop here to e7 or bishop here to
d6 we can castle on the King side we
Castle and then again just continue to
see what our opponent does we could
Knight here to c3 because we're not too
worried about any rook we can bring our
bishop here to e3 if we want to Bishop
here to f4 depending on how aggressive
we want to be Queen here to d2 and then
continue with our attack the last
variation that we're going to look at is
pawn to d6 I don't see it as much but
still somewhat frequent getting ready to
prepare with
57 to kind of stop this pin here on the
knight on c6 White's gonna continue with
the same game plain he's gonna play
Bishop takes on c6 after the pawn takes
right here white plays pawn to d3
solidifying that pawn chain once again
now again it depends on what black wants
to do he could play this pawn to d5
we're not gonna take we don't want to
take and then have our opponent again
control the center of the board no
longer has double pawns
again always look at the center of the
board and see if you actually want to
take or if you just can continue with
your own game playing again from here
white can play at Knight to c3 not too
worried about too much can't really play
pawn here to d4 because Knight over here
to a4 what we talked about is gonna be
completely fine from white now if
instead of pawn to d5 another mode we
could see is pawn to e5 White's now just
going to castle on the King side not too
worried about too much if we now see the
rook over here to b8 we can continue
with before rook to b8 we know the game
plan Knight over here to d2 if we see
bishop here too you said a little bit
different because the bishops not
feeding Kadota on the King side we can
now play Knight to c4 again very
centralized square for this Knight
attacking a lot of critical squares can
always bring it over to a5 if we wanted
to but again attacking this pawn here on
the six kind of a disruptor can't really
attack it with pawn here to d5 because
it can swing over here and take on e5
and it also has a protector here with
this pawn here on f3 so if we come back
instead of E 5 another thing that we
could see is our opponent deciding to
play pawn to g6 makes a lot of sense get
ready and keto on the King side this is
again very similar to what we've seen
before you don't have to memorize
anything new we're gonna be castling on
the King side your opponent plays Bishop
over here to g6 and then white can
continue with Knight here to d2 if he
wants to so again this is the Rose oh
look rosalie mo of variation and the
Sicilian offense hopefully you guys
learn something Sicilian defense
definitely one of the strongest defenses
from
so anytime you have another weapon in
your arsenal to go ahead and fight your
opponents and actually give them some
discomfort when they're playing the
Sicilian defense I definitely recommend
it so hopefully you guys enjoyed
hopefully you learned something and I'll
see you on the next video
thanks for watching